[Music]
how many of you guys
started cooking more often when the
pandemic started
yeah it goes in waves yeah i think we've
been cooking so i don't think
it's more but it's about the same i
guess about the same i barely
eat out now really exactly i just get
order food yeah
recipes that are really fast i just
found like a couple recipes super fast
so then i just make those that's true
yeah same like
for me i think it was like before it was
like
let's let's let's try new recipes but
when the pandemic happened it was like
okay let's just simplify the recipes and
it's just like cook whatever's available
and things like that
and yeah we don't we aren't ordering out
as often as we used to and obviously
we're not going out to eat
are you guys going out to eat we do yeah
you guys yeah you sit in the out
outdoors and stuff
having something nice it's too high
isn't it at all
um it's hot but i think it's like
better than being at home all the time
so it's a good like little
break little change of scenery yeah
we've only done it twice though we
did once at a diner that served
breakfast
and then we did it in k-town and then
italian food
township yeah three times
we did it in santa barbara they had
opened up
they basically state street is like the
main street in santa barbara
and they shut down the whole street to
cars so cars couldn't go through cool
and then all the restaurants put their
tables and chairs in the street and like
so it's right outside of there and it's
all cool
yeah so it's like kind of like a
festival but yeah you're going
to go in inside the restaurant yeah
that's crazy but yeah so there's a
studying right now that i guess these
studies are happening everywhere
but the fact that people are cooking
more often at home
has led to less food waste and which
that
is helping out with climate change right
now so that's a pretty cool little
byproduct of the pandemic
uh and some uh some some some numbers
for you guys before the pandemic
american food waste amounted to about 30
to 40 percent
that's like [ __ ] half the plate if
you go if you go to a restaurant that's
half the plate is not eaten and it's
being tossed out and
the estimate here is that based on
usda's economic research service of 31
food loss at the retail consumer levels
that
corresponds to about 133 billion pounds
of food being wasted which is 161
billion
dollars worth of food whoa they should
just make the portion smaller
the portions are [ __ ] up no i want the
deal and i want it to be big
true true and you always have a
stomachache always
do you throw out your food steve so so
as someone that is pro
uh big plate yes yeah you like
he eats everything on the plate and then
if i can't finish he eats my leftovers
that's what's up and then later when i'm
like hey he's like
a tummy ache i ate a lot [ __ ] i
i i got too much i got a dad so much
you cockblocked yourself i know dude
that's that's the [ __ ] about uh
uh nice romantic dates because then like
when me and tiff are like go on a
romantic date and stuff it's like all
right cool we know where this is going
to lead at the end of the night
that's what you think that's what i
think exactly and then when we go out to
like these romantic dinners i'm like oh
[ __ ] we're like paying extra
for like to be here right now let's
let's get something good and let's make
sure we're full
too and then by the time i get home i'm
[ __ ] either too drunk or too full
and the remaining i always have
leftovers leftovers if
we go to a fancy place and i get a nice
dish and i'm like hell yeah i stopped
when i'm full
but then i'm like i'm getting good lunch
tomorrow all right i'm gonna take that
home
and i'm like excuse me you said it's
endless spaghetti
you cheap i'm at the olive garden i'm
here for
the endless bottomless spaghetti please
the [ __ ] bread sticks hey pals all
you can eat soup and salad
i like to i like to sit down and i say
when do you close
i i tell the the kitchen steve has
arrived that's right
do you think the buffets in vegas will
get shut down for a while like for are
going to go out of business because like
how
i love those for the foreseeable future
right so you think it's going to be a
thing of the
they're back open the buffet i don't
think the buffets are oh because the
outside looks like
if it's popping off everyone's not
socially oh yeah the streets if you see
pictures of the streets
it looks popping like nothing ever
happened yeah yeah a lot of casinos
aren't open too though
they're nuts yeah well not a lot but
there's a lot of hotels that just
they're not running i'll go there yeah
wait how do you go if they're not
running no i would go there i would go
to where the poppin party oh right yeah
why wouldn't i
no yeah you know there's a stat of
189 case
of people that went to vegas ended up
getting corona
189 yeah i like those
it's like a for sure on man hey that
doesn't get lucky
right you don't hear those odds in vegas
very often never do
funny the house doesn't always win i
know right
but yeah have you guys uh been a lot
more uh cookies
like with cooking like are you guys
saving your food more and like eating
leftovers yeah i don't have any food
waste anymore
it's crazy yeah that's like in our
household it's it's it's still like a
struggle to get like
i grew up eating leftovers right and i
feel like it might be a cultural thing
like with like asian
uh like families it's that we always eat
leftovers and stuff but with like isaac
and tiff they didn't we
poor like you casey we don't [ __ ] eat
the leftovers
that's what it seems like that's how i
feel i'm like it's not beneath me you
shouldn't be beneath you to eat some
leftovers if you know we'd save some
money or whatever you know
i just hated that when i was a kid
because we always had leftovers and we
had to eat leftovers the next night and
i like not having to do that now
really yeah yeah steve won't eat
leftovers but i love leftovers to me
it's like free
food too because that's how i see it and
it still tastes good
yeah it's already cooked it's already
ready to go i see it as rebel
i'm a rebel and i i don't have to do
what my mom says anymore
but then you're always scrounging for
food
yeah i know i'm very hungry so like
there's leftovers and you're like
there's like pad thai from yesterday
sitting right there yeah
yeah delicious pad thai left over casey
has his dignity i don't get it i was
raised in a household with four
other kids so what so we it was a
[ __ ]
war so you had to fight over the
leftovers yes
okay i don't want to eat leftovers now
my my dad grew up in a house with more
kids than you
who he had five brothers and sisters
yeah well we had a bigger house
you know what okay yeah so they he had
to fight more with his brothers and
sisters and we all
eat leftovers still the only one that's
bougie is my [ __ ] brother
he won't eat leftovers really yeah me
and my mom and dad were all like
it's free food i don't i don't like um
mexican food leftovers though
that's good that's probably well there's
a lot of fresh ingredients that
are required to eat it fresh it just
tastes nasty if you
you eat it again yeah it doesn't quite
work i mean i know that's not like the
most mexican of all mexican foods but
like you can't heat up a burrito
and be like oh yeah the tomatoes and the
lettuce and the guacamole that's in
there that's still good after being
microwaved
that's done maybe a quesadilla i'm trash
i'll basically eat anything left over
like if i ordered it yeah and it's my
leftovers i'll eat it
there's something comforting about
leftovers and then
mixing leftovers like if you have like
they're purposing it
repurposing is pretty good two or three
different restaurants
yup then you kind of get like a little
action
yeah i like that [ __ ] you can hook up
your plate and stuff
does anyone ever take pictures of their
leftover plates no
i'm [ __ ] weird i'm like dude i hooked
myself
up and i made it real pretty i'll take a
picture of it
never post it and it'll just have like a
whole bunch of food photos in my day
dude you should have
a food instagram that's just repurposed
leftovers
like leftover page oh yeah because i do
that and i take pride in that too
like if i can make fried rice out of it
or something and it tastes
good or better exactly because you mixed
like two three different things and you
got it and you're just like
yo that works look at you guys you're
judging us
in our house like we just put anything
any leftovers over rice
it's a new dish exactly take all your
leftovers put it over fresh rice
and the best of all i'm just sitting
here going i just turned 20 bucks
into five [ __ ] meals man but listen
to yourself though you're saying you're
like
it almost tastes fresh i got it so close
to the taste like something else yeah it
tastes like something else yeah
you you made it's like you invented
something new with it as a master of the
deals i'm like
i know right no i still like the deals
damn nikki icebreakers
icebreaker so he's the iceman of the
icebreaker huh no ice man
ice breaker didn't stick iceman as well
did it not because uh
that's the word on the streets i saw it
tagged up outside yeah mickey icebreaker
was here just breaking the ice
sorry steve i like icebreaker that's a
that's a good name i think we need to
write that uh
damn dude i see you melting it's okay
they they used to call me ace too so
i'll go with i'll go with that one right
now
she's the only one that can conquer the
arctic exactly
pam no no what do you yeah
i don't know man i think that like
there's so many good things about
repurposing food and leftovers and all
that where like you're saving money
you're just [ __ ]
you're not wasting food and then you can
taste something different and it's fast
yeah i think that's the thing is if you
could cook like it's
faster to grab all the leftovers and
just run it through the microwave or
just on a [ __ ] you don't know how to
cook because it
fl like it makes you exercise your
creative muscle
to [ __ ] it could be a gateway to
cooking exactly because
that's why i like it because then i'm
just like oh [ __ ] someone already made
it so like i can already
understand what flavors are happening
here oh [ __ ] i could put this oh [ __ ] it
changed it
or sometimes you just have this like
craving for that one specific flavor
like buffalo sauce
where i'm like i don't make buffalo
sauce but i had buffalo sauce on that
stuff last night and then i'm like oh
yeah it's in the fridge still and i get
really excited
like you're trying to start spooning the
buffalo sauce like i don't put on this
thing yeah now
i try to waste not nothing right so i
even got the rinds from my watermelon
and i [ __ ] made
i got chicken and i made the soup out of
that wow
ryan's was it good that's the next level
[ __ ] what if he's like no
it's just like a melon it's like a melon
and then you just
you just [ __ ] boil it and it becomes
a fiber uh julie zahn actually made me a
watermelon rind soup one time
and then i was like what the hell this
is crazy wait is that a thing
you're chinese you say it like you say
what she did
as if it was an actual thing like she
aimed to do this like it was like a pass
down
she said that her grandma made it for
her so i was like i didn't know you
could eat that sounds like my grandma
also
cooked her bunny looked her what her
bunny oh [ __ ] but
there's also so many things you can eat
that uh
bunny and watermelon like this she
doesn't waste time
this is too ethnic for me guys it was a
good deal actually oh really that's
great what's your other stances on not
eating leftovers
do you think what's your other stance is
so far it's just like i grew up in a
cute in a house with two i think that
that's why i think is
that i don't like like to do it i'll do
it it's just psychological
i think i just i just look at it as like
i don't have to do this anymore
yeah i challenge you guys to eat
everything in your fridge in your pantry
and see how long it goes for me it took
me three weeks
until i folded to buy more things but i
could have gone
further longer is it a race because if
it's a race i could make it disappear
like a day or two
saving money there it's not
to show you guys that we stockpile a lot
of what we do yeah
yeah yeah yeah and we never so it's like
it's like this it's like you have a car
right you don't [ __ ] drive your car
to empty
you just keep driving it to half and you
keep filling it back up
so that's basically what we're doing but
you can really stretch it out for a long
time i could probably have gone for over
a month
yeah for me i think it's because i grew
up not so
financially well off so there were a lot
of things that i wanted and now that i
can afford it i'm like i'm getting that
[ __ ] even if i don't eat it
i'm like satisfying my inner pantry is
all lunchables
and candy there's a ton of candy in
there and everything's [ __ ] name
brand news are not
[ __ ] good they're nasty i never liked
this awful why did i love it
i always want to just heat it up like
it's just eating it cold is this good
frozen meat in your freezer that's been
there for months
oh yeah the most is maybe three or four
months yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying man use them i
got a giant
of uh like an unchopped rib eye
in there use that [ __ ] for me it's the
dried goods like rice and pasta
i have so much rice that's apocalypse
food i know
that lasts forever but the thing is the
sauces you know you need to get sauces
you